hardly anyone has raised more
conscientious imaginative children than
the legendary mid-century children's
book editor Ursula Nordstrom who brought
to life such multi-generational classics
as Margaret wise Brown good night moon
EB White's Charlotte's Web shel
Silverstein's The Giving Tree and
Maurice Sendak's where the wild things
are during her long tenure at Harper &
row Nordstrom was not just an editor to
her authors at her artists but their
friend their confident their therapists
their greatest champion always she stood
up against censorship and constantly
bolstered the creative confidence of
these young writers and artists she was
especially instrumental in the life of
maurice sendak who might not be who we
know him as today without her and she by
the way was a beautiful letter writer
her letters are collected in a book
called dear genius by the children's
book historian Leonard Marcus so in one
exchange with Sendak he wrote to her
despairing over having been commissioned
to illustrate the work of Tolstoy and
feeling utterly inadequate to match
Tolstoy his genius and so she wrote to
him and said you may not be Tolstoy but
Tolstoy was in sandack either you have a
vast and beautiful genius this
emboldened Sendak enormously and by the
following year he was already working on
his very own where the wild things are
which went on to become one of the most
beloved children's books of all time but
most of all Nordstrom defended the world
and the experience of the child against
all the commercial pressures for
commodities and conformity and politely
boring storytelling that dominated
children's books at the time and so the
most benevolent patron saint of modern
childhood ended up being a gay woman
working at the height of consumerism and
somehow managing to publish and envision
and defend books that were not
forgettable commodities but
extraordinary master works that stood
the test of time and moved and inspired
and enchanted generations
you